a majority of women say they've
experienced at least one safety related
incident or concern while traveling now
yesterday we introduced you to sherry
Marchand of the mother of three who was
sexually assaulted in her hotel room
while traveling for work in 2014
according to court documents her
assailant got a key to her room from
hotel staff without any security checks
CBS this morning Saturday co-host Dana
Jacobson spoke with mark Shonda and is
here with some tips on how to protect
yourself Dana good morning good morning
Marchand I thought she did everything
right to protect herself in that hotel
like locking the door and putting on
that safety bolt but there were some
things that came as a surprise to her in
the wake of the attack things that
actually may be a surprise to some of
you watching it's like home away from
home I even look at some of the
advertising and that's exactly what
their marketing is that you know this is
this is your refuge when you're on the
road this is a place where you can kick
back and relax and feel safe while
staying at this Embassy Suites in Des
Moines Iowa Shari Marsh Shanda says she
felt safe in large part because she
believed in the brand Hilton you walk in
and you see the name and you're trusting
within the name and through this process
I learned that it's not theirs owners
operators franchisees you know so you
thought this was Hilton in charge of
everything yeah I think that's something
that has to be more recognizable that
when we go it's not necessarily a Hilton
or a Marriott or a Hyatt it is somebody
like in my case you know an
owner/operator situation in fact many of
these big brand hotels are franchises
meaning the owners and managers operate
independently the court ultimately ruled
that as the guestroom key control
Embassy Suites and Hilton did not have
ultimate responsibility Peter Volare
Marsh shonda's attorney says that even
though this Embassy Suites is branded a
Hilton the management company John Q
Hammonds and owner atrium hospitality
were ultimately responsible for giving
Christopher Lapointe access to Marchand
Eze room where he sexually assaulted and
raped her in the middle of the night
that seems like a huge surprise to most
people
that a brand name is on a hotel and they
wouldn't be responsible for everything I
think within the industry we learned
that it's quite common I've had other
cases like this things get made by
different people even though there's
labels on them you could be wearing a
jacket
by a name brand and it's made in China
or anywhere in the world by some other
company so it works similarly in the
hotel industry even the hotels that have
the best names in terms of the brand may
present a risk of harm to you
women's rights attorney Gloria Allred
has represented several hotel assault
victims including Kayla snipe who was
raped in her hotel room in 2013 my hotel
room key was given to my attacker by
hotel staff snipes attacker was given a
key to her room without an ID check at
this Embassy Suites in South Carolina
every precaution should be taken by
someone who's checking into a hotel then
no one else is authorized to be in that
room or to be given a key the case
settled out of court in the hotel
industry do better I think any industry
can always do better when it comes to
safety and security attorney and
professor of hospitality law Stephen
Barth says travelers should be proactive
about their safety
when we get to the hotel front desk
don't provide your name out loud if the
front desk agent calls your room number
out loud you need to request a different
room when you sign off on the guest
check if you're billing it to the room
hand that receipt with your information
back to the server so that you know it's
in the custody and control of the hotel
and not some random person do companies
need to catch up when it comes to their
travel and their security yes businesses
need to recognize that they're asking
people to go out and do things on their
behalf and that they need to take an
active role in teaching and training
them about how to be safe and secure
when they travel as for sherry Marchand
uh she now uses a portable door lock
that helps her feel a little safer again
while on the road I have a lock that I
found
and I use that everywhere I go in fact I
carry two in case someone gets me I
always request no connecting doors but I
always carry two just in case I get that
and a variety of portable door locks are
easily available online if you do a
search or even a simple rubber doorstop
can help secure a hotel door now a few
other things to keep in mind we're told
when you're in the elevator don't push
your floor number first and if someone
gets out on your floor
let them go ahead of you if you're
concerned at all go down to the front
desk and request one room key so you
always know where it is important to
note that Hilton was not involved in
Marsh ondas lawsuit but the company did
tell us it maintains rigorous safety
standards for Hilton managed properties
and expects the same of its franchised
hotels really good advice Dana because I
always thought you put the deadbolt on
and certainly the chain that you're okay
right and I've never heard of a portable
door lock before yeah and there really
are a variety of them different sizes
different types you do have to remember
this means that if there was an
emergency the hotel staff may not be
able to get in to help you but I think
when you talk to people about their
safety and they want to feel more secure
those door locks or even that rubber
door stopper can make a difference think
be smart and don't be afraid to speak up
you've got to be assertive when it comes
to your safe good advice about the if
they call it your hotel room number that
just happened to me the other day and I
go okay thank you and ask agent yeah ask
them to change it exists on it Thank You
Dana sure you can see more of our
interview with sherry Marchand including
her emotional account of how the attack
changed her life go to our website that
cBS This Morning Calm we will be right
back